marry winch and match runs 30 works it's
art made from the stuff that moose leave
behind the terms that I used to name
these products or everyday terms that
people are used to hearing and what we
did see is we took them turns and we
crammed them in between the number there
so that's one thirty two thirty three
thirty that's just one of the many
products she offers now over here we
make fecal people and depending upon the
shape of the middle turds right there we
can do with big boobs or guts or butt so
long legs a short leg see cuz there's no
two turds under ever light you ever seen
the two turns light no dirty works is
the ultimate mom and plop business no
she's not max mother on always sunny I
crazy scat lady is married from Maine
but she loves playing with poop so much
you'd swear she was from Germany she
waits all day for moose to do so she can
turn those turds into treasures she's a
true master of arts and craps unlike
every other Etsy store she's honest
about the fact that she's selling you
pure the day I set foot inside a
craft stores the day I pin a suicide
note to my vision board Hobby Lobby
loves crafting so much even their stance
on abortion is do-it-yourself say what
you will about their politics but
there's no better place on the planet to
buy styrofoam balls of varying size I'm
sure this bedazzled Keiko Z will look
amazing in my trash can but I'm not
Pinterest it in any gift you've made by
hand
give me something was made by tiny
third-world children hands you overpaid
chubby Americans don't have the
dexterity but there's something about
Mary mainly that she talks funny which
is why I flew her to hollywood where we
know a thing or two about polishing a
turd for this week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
[Music]
I've got a one-of-a-kind Peter Dinklage
dookey right here it's half off don't
alter to look like Peter Dinklage hey
got Chris Pratt's cat I got the guy from
Rudy's duty and Mamma Mia
I even got Meryl Streep's diarrhea but
the real prize this baby right here a
whopper from Emma Watson wait there's
two celebrity pupuce Wow that's my
brother okay he sells turds that look
like celebrities I'm selling their
actual brown gold here that's
half-brother your mom's a whore Mary
how's business
hey great how you doing mind if I pull
up a stool pull up a stool pun intended
all right Mary where are you from I am
from Maine where it made some of the
Maine
can I smell your fingers you can't if
you want let's get to this nonsense
first of all why do you spell turds with
an eye I think that Webster's dictionary
has it wrong I think that someone didn't
think it out real good because if you
look at the word bird it's bir d so bird
turd so it should be spelled tird you
smoke marijuana yes we have some
products that relate to that too like
what we have a clip oh that's a
good idea yes and you put a joint on
that and pass that around how long
have you been dealing with these moose
turds been doing it about 15 years
really yes
just so I know how many helots are in a
single dropping for a moose they'll
typically out two to four hundred
turns every time they take a dump that's
gotta feel amazing oh it's exciting you
know in just like changing I mean you
watch a church come out of their ass and
it's like 5 10 15 20 like playing Wheel
of Fortune slot machines actually
typically we'll get a hundred to 150
pounds of turds every time we go out in
the woods you know we put them in bags
and sling them over the shoulder and
drag them out and by the time we get out
with pooped oh yes how fresh will you
grab them I like him as fresh and juicy
as I can get them the longer they sit in
the woods they'll get punky and dry it
out you know and that kind of
compromises the product product
integrity so to speak something prime oh
that's nice
do you use hand sanitizer oh good to
know
no I turns are good you need to go out
in the woods with us collect and turn
someday I don't want to collect herds
you can violate you out the woods we're
violating the same where do you sell all
this stuff we sell it at craft fairs
we're not online he's ordered online is
it legal to mail poop
it is the products are non hazardous
essentially you could eat it have you
ever tasted one I've put one in my mouth
before did you bite down a little bit
do you coat the turds er well yeah we
have two different kinds of coatings we
use because some people like a
natural-looking turd and some people
like it when that turds glisten oh you
know we want to please everyone
oh no it's nice of you only mousse no we
have cow turds - oh really
yes we have a couple right there one of
them we call a bull and the other
one we call a cow a Dunga so you just
put a turn on the piece of wood yeah I'm
not a product where they turn candles
their candles - it's a little earthy we
actually have a scratch-and-sniff fairy
right there to validate the fact that I
don't stink she ever think you'd
outgrow poop jokes it's healthy getting
worse with age what's your best seller
the poopoo clocks in the fecal people oh
my god the fecal people yes now
depending upon the shape of their middle
turds right there we can do with the big
boobs or guts or butt so long legs or
short legs
why can't be so the vehicle people be
genderless oh nice but we did develop a
couple fecal people down here that do
have gender art oh we did blue did turds
for the for the boobies and for the
ding-dong and stuff those are gonna go
on top of web cake oh that's nice yes
that's where they should go a wedding
cake okay the dartboard yeah that's just
that's a crapshoot
you didn't wrap some velcro slowly it's
brilliant it's not that
mind that well they just gonna do that
all the waters for it this is what I
wanted to show you right here
the keychains see now due to the
high-fiber diet of a moose the turds
float yeah you ever dropped the key in
the water you're gonna look for a
floating turd and M key is gonna be
dangling right underneath that turn for
the bizarre make easy well you have to
cram an extra turn on if you've had a
lot of keys okay a janitor they wouldn't
they would have done exactly a power
dump
so you're saying with the key chain you
just keep poop in your pocket absolutely
have you ever used human no Oh
gross that's gross the tube it turns I
wouldn't touch a human turd but they
probably don't even flow some do Wow
I'm not gonna go around figuring that
out well thank you worried by touching
that how often you get pinkeye I've
never had pinkeye really a pink eye from
human poop I've no I actually how you
get pinkeye from getting poop in your
eye so you can get it from any kind of
poop though that would be like a shitty
idea what shitty idea we have that it's
right here there's a little turds in
that dear I write that that's a shitty
idea come on no I don't sell it that's
one of my prob I don't you oh you got
like a like a Gallagher what's this go
for 15 bucks how much does the trade
cause without poop in it 20 that's a
poopoo platter I mean the tray alone
I've I scraped all this poop out that's
a nice good tray I'm starting to
understand your business model what
you're doing is taking existing products
and gluing turns to them
it's brilliant thank you people I have a
few ideas of how we can expand your
brand excellent what do you got what
about poop holes hardware for all your
kitchen cabinets instantly devalue your
home socks socks yeah take
your socks okay film with moose turds
throw in the microwave 30 to 45 seconds
then when your foot goes in oh it's
gonna feel so nice
about frozen diarrhea cubes now your
cocktails won't get watered down by
normal ice that's a good idea - thank
you
by the way any idea that I give you is
100% yours free and clear all right I
saved my biggest and shittiest idea for
last we take the greenest car on the
road and make it brown I'm calling it
the turd tesla model BM isn't she a
beaut yeah she is holding you $1,000 to
pre-order estimated delivery of five
years what's the cost it's the price of
a regular Tesla Plus poops and labor
it's got that new car smell and you can
use the carpool lane
you